so i go in version i go into sentence
mode and try to match the audio to the
sentence that i'm working on and i do
try to listen as i'm reading
uh because otherwise it's not clear to
me how the words are pronounced but then
i go in
[Music]
hello shelby hello steve
how are you i'm great thanks how are you
good thank you boy i don't know about uh
down in portland but we're having a sort
of a good summer now like we had a
terrible july or first half of july
right
uh but it's been really day after day
after day it's just beautiful weather
how about down there exactly the same
here i was just recollecting that the
first two weeks of july were still kind
of cold and gray
um but yeah the last wet wet up here but
anyway yeah not not as wet down here but
yeah it's been hot i just bought an air
conditioning unit
good good
comfort is good better late than never
right
um so have you had much chance to work
on your french
um
a little bit not as much as i would like
to but i'm at
30 in the mini stories
okay and um i've been i'm so interested
in watching these like inner french
videos and
um listening to songs so i'm i'm still
practicing but i'm moving kind of slow
in my mini stories but
you know what couple of comments like
people should do what they want to do
and
listen to what you like to listen to
in fact i was just thinking about this
you know listening is so important uh
maybe when we get into sharing your
screen we can show people how they
create playlists
and how they can listen to the course
audio so that they can easily get
the audio onto their
device whatever they like to use their
iphone or android or whatever
you know listening and over and over
again it's it just gets your brain used
to the language gets your brain used to
the sounds of the language i certainly
listened a lot and repetitively to
these comic dialogues to get the tones
in chinese
uh but french
pronunciation which some people find
difficult and they sometimes find the
comprehension difficult
just that listening listening listening
pounding your brain it's just such a
good thing to do
and
then if you do a lot of listening and
then you follow up by reading you then
have some momentum
so that because when we read in a
foreign language we tend to pronounce to
ourselves in our own minds
and so you want to be pronouncing it
correctly right
you know as close as possible to
correctly when you pronounce to yourself
you you do pronounce correctly because
you're in fact not pronouncing it so
right you know what i mean exactly
there's no way you can make a mistake
but so i i just keep on yeah so
listening is just so super super
powerful yeah and we do make it very
easy only which we'll show later on but
so you're listening and
you know i like the many stories because
the amount of repetition
uh i find that when i listen to
something that's more interesting like i
had my uh
sahara who's my collaborator in iran
sent through a friend of hers
talked about herself how she
you know she studied
you know chemistry but couldn't get a
job in in industry so she set up her own
online business selling
organic health products but her real
interest is writing and so now she has
time to write so here you are you're
connecting with this person
in iran who's talking about herself and
stuff like that
but i can't listen to that 10 times
because when i'm listening for out of
interest that's one kind of listening
whereas when i'm listening to the many
stories i'm listening for rhythm i'm
listening to notice things about the
language
personally i find that if i'm listening
to notice things in the language
then that's what i focus on if i'm
listening out of interest
then i'm less attentive to some of the
details of the language so there are
different ways to listen that's very
interesting that makes complete sense
yeah you're um like whatever your
intention is
for what you're listening for
will
certainly kind of change your experience
right so i think it's a good idea to do
both and and of course
you're absolutely you're doing the right
thing moving into things of interest as
soon as you can
because we encourage people not to stay
with sort of beginner material
but at the same time it's good to mix in
some of that you know what i call your
core activities you know yeah get back
in there and work on your basic
comprehension sense of the language
rhythm of the language to vary it do
both and you know something that we talk
about a lot with link is emphasis on
listening and reading and something that
i clarified with a another link learner
that i was talking to is that listening
and reading
doesn't necessarily mean at the same
time
like you in particular i mean i you
definitely say that you you listen to
your playlist a lot you listen listen
listen when you're doing other things
and then you come back to read the same
text later to fill in those gaps and say
okay how was that spelled what did i
miss when i was listening etc and
uh so i think it's important for
everyone to understand that listening
and reading doesn't have to happen at
the same time if that's not feasible for
you and in fact it sounds like you don't
really do it that way at all you listen
and read at different times is that
right no i
you know i think i do all of the above
so
obviously when i'm doing the dishes in
the car i'm only listening
i also like sitting down and reading
because i'm reading in a language which
has a difficult writing system either
arabic or persian
i use the text to speech in arabic but
it's not available in persian so i go in
version i go into sentence mode and try
to match the audio to the sentence that
i'm working on and i do try to listen as
i'm reading
because otherwise it's not clear to me
how the words are pronounced but then i
go away and listen on on just you know
listening
uh so i i think you can do all three uh
early on if it's a difficult language
you want to listen and read at the same
time you want to take every opportunity
to listen to you know find
you know 10 15 minutes here or there to
do listening during the day and there
are also times when we just want to read
and look up words and i think all three
activities are great
and it's just another area where we can
have variety in our activities so we we
never get bored
yep
okay
so
with that so we're gonna maybe
get into your
uh link page and just
focus on many stories we're gonna speak
a little bit of french but also maybe
show how
easy it is to get that listening the the
audio of your lessons onto a playlist
okay in one form or another yes okay
okay
all right
all right so here we are
here are my lessons do you want to pop
into the playlist first
it can do sure
okay so actually i personally don't ever
manage my playlist from the desktop i
find that if you go into a lesson
it will be automatically added to your
playlist
okay repeat that again because that's
very important right so if you go into a
lesson
right and any lesson that you just open
and right i mean i'm already in my
lessons but if i'm starting from the
library and i click on a lesson that i
think looks interesting right it's going
to be saved in my lessons
and
the audio is going to be added to my
playlist
okay now if we go back to that other
view where you showed the list of your
lessons it also shows whether it is in
your playlist or not right
if it does i haven't uh noticed that
but you know and i'll confess that i
hadn't really focused on the fact that
all lessons are automatically added to
my playlist yeah i see it
you see is this the icon for playing
yeah yeah so if it's colored and it's if
you go down the page to a lesson you
haven't opened
or there's one that you oh you so you
never opened it that one didn't get
added to my playlist for something
strange
all right let's go down first i was like
listening to the mini stories this
morning on my phone okay so there you go
31 you haven't yet added to your
playlist so these are all added
automatically you didn't add them
manually
you know i don't use that just to show
go back up top again
just to show people the different
options for what you know we we end up
doing what we're used to doing
and i think i find this if i learn to do
something one way then that's the way
i'm going to do it and and then yeah
sometimes i miss out on better ways
but i will go and play the course audio
and i will always do that on my
iphone or my ipod
play course audio if you move your
cursor to the right
no to the right no to the well over to
the right oh over here okay yeah
so
you know because i don't listen on the
computer it's not a great place to do it
but if you're on your iphone or ipod i
tend to go to you know my course look at
my courses choose a course whichever
course because i'm popping around
different courses
but i tend to want to stay in a course i
don't really want to be jumping around
too much although mark likes to jump
around because he likes the variety of
jumping around
i will go to the course it says play
course audio on my player android or
iphone
and then i can shuffle them if i want
but at least i'm if i'm in the mini
stores i'm in the mini stores and
they'll shuffle around
right so i will play use the blank horse
audio from my portable device not from
here yeah exactly so this
so this would just play all of my mini
stories right click on it click on it
and click on play course
okay
and so
somewhere
oh you got to hit the down arrow no the
michelle no no here on our yeah
click on that so there you got all your
you know lessons only you can scroll you
know shuffle them if you want or
whatever you want to do right shuffle
here
so yeah and if anyone um
i mean i hope that everyone uses their
playlist on their phone but if you're
not familiar with it it's just one of
the buttons on the bottom
menu when you open the application so if
you click on your playlist you might
want to check out what you have on there
and if there's other stuff that you want
to add it's easy to do it from this page
go to the lesson click on this button
and then it should appear because it
syncs
web yeah i mean i encourage people to do
a lot of listening because it's so easy
to do
uh it's something you can do five
minutes here or five minutes there
and it is very powerful and particularly
when combined with reading not
necessarily always reading and listening
at the same time but reading something
that you listen to and didn't understand
and then reading it and listening again
and maybe understanding a little bit
more
but still not completely and then going
back so anyway let's go you choose the
lesson you want to open
all right so i discovered a a new
narrator later in the mini stories this
guy has a great voice so
by the way we are looking at just
because the subject came up and a lot of
people agreed that the french was
perhaps spoken too quickly or it wasn't
she had didn't have a pleasant voice or
whatever it was so we are looking at all
of our uh mini stories and wherever we
think the voice is not pleasant or the
quality of the sound isn't good or
spoken too quickly we're going to amend
those but it's not gonna happen
overnight but we are working on that
sure and i noticed some of the maybe
some or all of the numbers are now being
typed out yes that's another thing we
discovered yes so that was helpful for
me yes yes absolutely i was able to
start adding those numbers as links now
well yeah i mean it's not obvious that
the word
meaning 20 is written v-i-n-g-t
no
you know you want to save those
okay
so you can whichever one you want to
whatever up to you where you want to go
okay
um
do you want to go to a new lesson or one
that we've you've already covered
um i think that because
you know full disclosure i haven't been
studying every single day like i should
be um things got a little bit busy yeah
um i i'm excited to get back into it
more uh consistently but because i would
like to hear uh do one that at least i
heard before
okay you know what we should do because
we said we're going to start speaking
why don't you take us straight to the
questions here okay
and you're going to try to answer some
of the questions
okay
so should i read the statement read the
statement
okay and and then i will ask the
question and you will give the answer
okay perfect
right it's just that inconsistency of
when the liaison is there and isn't
there someone commented by them i said
that you don't carry that the p doesn't
get liaison
uh but someone else said no i've heard
french people you you know dragged the
people
i'm trying to think of an example
you can say
i very much want to jai video
but i guess some people say beaucoup avi
i haven't heard it but a french person
said yes people do
drag the p on so we'll probably get some
comments back from native speakers
anyway looking forward to it right so
give us a statement again for nimrod
perfect
see what they give us as a translation
look at that very impatient or very yeah
it can also have the sense of looking
forward
yes what if you say
what do you save the whole thing
they're very very excited okay so in
english impatient is just impatient but
in french it has a somewhat broader
meaning
right uh hugo cotton from inner french
did a great lesson on
not
not trying to
translate
um literally you know from english to
french and it's the same with spanish
too um so and he also mentioned which
something i have not seen in the mini
stories which is j
yeah
is that similar
is so you can say jayat i you know i'm
really anxious to i'm looking forward to
i can't wait jayat is i can't wait to do
something
haste
at is the word haste right i have
noticed oh okay
i i wanna i wanna get going i'm whereas
the word looking forward you very often
hear
jato avec anticipation
i am waiting with anticipation
so i'm very much looking forward to the
visit of my best friend
they all have slightly different
meanings and so therefore the key is to
save them in different contexts and just
get a sense of how they're used okay
yeah definitely
on the next page
i was going to try to read it
i was just going to try to answer
without uh without reading it um
oh yeah right you are yeah try to answer
without reading good okay okay i i
didn't read it okay come
and remember that you know you don't
hear the ent you don't hear the e after
the third person singular
it's one of those things sometimes you
don't know if it's singular or plural
what one thing i noticed about
these ones these mini stories in the 20s
is that they're using more of a
combination of vocabulary rather than
just repeating the exact same words
right like yo
versus
song or
it's just not right
yeah and right like they feel or they
are i mean right different ways to
portray the same thing right i think
they they tend to repeat the same words
but they sometimes depending on who you
know
what was written in english and the the
mood of the translator we can get
different uh different words
okay yeah
i like the way this guy's doing it
the thing is too that um you know so
often you know we're used to
in tests you know that there's only one
right answer well in real life there's
more than one right answer oh yeah so
anyway let's do one more and i think
that'll be good for today okay
you're going to queue me up
[Music]
very good the only thing he missed was
zoom fee
but you know what don't even
think about it because if you do a lot
of listening
these things start to become natural i
think one of the worst things people do
is they beat themselves up over things
that they continue to get wrong and we
will continue to get them wrong until
one day we no longer do and i know when
i have my lessons in you know persian
arabic turkish whatever and i have my
notes from my my tutor sends me my my my
mistakes a list right that i study as a
lesson and i make the same mistakes
every week
like three weeks in a row four weeks in
a row but eventually i stopped making
those mistakes so rather than beating
yourself up just wait for it naturally
to click in
that's i i think the more people get
down on themselves for what they can't
do or forget or whatever
all it does is gum up the learning
process not a good thing
yeah and i have to think of myself like
a baby who's just learning to speak and
eventually i learned how to speak
correctly in english right so i know the
same thing has to happen and it never
bothered you
exactly never probably didn't bother
your parents either
who knows but
at least they probably continue to
remind me how to say whatever probably
didn't even bother you
she'll get it one day okay do more
exposure
allah
salute
[Music]
you